y
bienvenidos a una nueva entrevista de
france 24 soy yo mismo y me acompaña al
señor imán you more enviado especial
para la paz de la unión europea a
colombia y también un representante
especial de derechos humanos de la unión
europea el señor gilmore está en una
gira en colombia para comprobar si se
están implementando los acuerdos de paz
de 2016 entre el estado colombiano y la
guerrilla de las farc y además para
comprobar la situación de derechos
humanos que vive colombia desde el
inicio de las protestas el pasado 28 de
abril muchas gracias señor gilmore por
estar con frank 24 es un placer estar
con ustedes la primera pregunta que le
quería hacer en usted llegó al cargo en
2015 de enviado especial para la paz a
colombia como es la situación seis años
después como que se ha encontrado aquí
en colombia
bueno primero que todo creo que la
negociación del acuerdo de paz en 2016 y
me siento muy honrado de haber podido
participar en alguna de las discusiones
que se llevaron a cabo para llegar a las
fases posteriores de la negociación que
se hicieron en la habana ese acuerdo de
paz le puso fin a un conflicto de 53
años en colombia el conflicto entre el
gobierno de colombia y las farc ha
salvado miles de vidas y no hay duda de
que el país es un lugar mucho más
pacífico a causa de eso acojo con
satisfacción el grado de implementación
del acuerdo de paz
por supuesto no ha sido implementado en
su totalidad y como con todos los
acuerdos de paz no ha sido implementado
de manera perfecta pero eso es algo que
se puede mejorar en pro venters perfecto
total expósito aniversario de la firma
del acuerdo ocurrirá más adelante este
año y creo que esa es una oportunidad
para que todos los involucrados
dupliquen los esfuerzos para implementar
el acuerdo en su totalidad implemente el
crimen sin fondo
durante el paro nacional france24 hemos
estado cubriendo en distintas partes de
colombia está en el sur occidente del
país cree usted que hay puntos olvidados
de ese acuerdo de paz como pueden ser la
reforma rural integral o la lucha contra
las drogas
wave un plan lo que el acuerdo de paz
estableció fue una fórmula para dejar
atrás las plantaciones de coca para
tener un proceso de sustitución de
cultivos se estableció un sistema de
compensación para agricultores y apoyo
para que cambiara a otros cultivos
legales se ha hecho algo de eso no se ha
hecho lo suficiente o fósforos están
esperando tener su consejo y
probablemente construir wikileaks el
rough trade and biggest paulo sigue
habiendo un problema persistente en el
país con el tráfico ilegal de drogas y
el mayor problema con este tráfico es la
violencia que viene asociada con él
en muchos lugares en particular lugares
remotos del país donde la producción de
coca es muy alta hemos visto el
asesinato de líderes sociales de
defensores de derechos humanos en
algunos casos de ex combatientes de las
farc estos son asuntos que nos preocupan
mucho
something that y estos asesinatos la
intimidación que viene con ellos es algo
que señalamos al gobierno colombiano de
manera regular y hablamos con las
autoridades para que haya más seguridad
en las áreas locales y para hacer rendir
cuentas a las personas responsables
supreme court count those were response
y cree usted que el gobierno de bando
que ha hecho todo posible para
implementar los acuerdos de paz o cree
que hay áreas vacías en esos acuerdos en
esos puntos de esa implementación
cuánto
bueno el presidente siempre ha dejado
claro las conversaciones que ha tenido
conmigo y con la unión europea su
compromiso con la implementación del
acuerdo hemos visto implementarse mucho
del acuerdo el desarme de las farc el
proceso de reincorporación de ex
combatientes de las farc los proyectos
económicos que se han establecido y
algunos de los cuales han sido
respaldados por la unión europea y en
particular se creó el funcionamiento del
sistema de justicia transicional el
sistema de justicia transicional que es
parte del acuerdo de paz en colombia es
único en el mundo y hemos visto algunas
decisiones muy únicas recientemente como
por ejemplo la decisión de
responsabilizar de manera colectiva a
los líderes de las farc por los
secuestros que ocurrieron durante el
conflicto y creo que es algo que no ha
pasado en ningún otro país o al menos
que yo sepa es el reconocimiento por
parte de líderes de las farc de esas
responsabilidades y su voluntad de
aceptar el juicio de la gente en este
examen
entonces estamos viendo implementar gran
parte del acuerdo hay muchas partes del
acuerdo en particular las que se
relacionan con las fuentes originales
del conflicto asuntos que tienen que ver
con la reforma agraria problemas
sociales participación política que
todavía deben ser implementados y es por
eso que cuando hablamos sobre la
implementación del acuerdo hablamos de
la importancia de implementar de manera
completa del acuerdo porque el acuerdo
era integral seis capítulos todos
interconectados entre ellos y eso es lo
que quisiéramos ver que ocurra y
seguiremos incentivando al gobierno y a
otros para que implementen enteramente
el acuerdo en su foro y entre mente y
red
profundizando en esa violencia que
comentaba hemos podido hablar bastante
con colectivos indígenas del cauca en el
suroccidente ellos nos comentan que
incluso la situación ahora es de más
riesgo riesgo que nunca para ellos
porque donde antes estaban las farc
ahora puede haber hasta ocho grupos
diferentes esta atomización qué
consecuencias puede tener en esta
implementación y si realmente hay como
comentan algunos analistas una
mexicanización del conflicto
efe
what's en productos confort
bueno creo que una de las consecuencias
del acuerdo final del conflicto con las
farc es que hubo partes del país que
estaban efectivamente controladas por
las farc y cuando el acuerdo se
implementó y las farc salieron de esas
áreas se reincorporaron a la sociedad
colombiana más amplia el vacío por
decirlo así se llenó con actores
ilegales muchos de ellos asociados al
tráfico de drogas fondos
anderson jesús ya raíz de eso vimos los
asesinatos de líderes sociales
asesinatos de defensores de derechos
humanos y en algunos casos los
asesinatos de ex combatientes de las
farc desde nuestra perspectiva eso ha
sido lo más preocupante en cuanto a la
implementación y el desarrollo más
preocupante desde el comienzo de la
implementación del acuerdo de paz es
algo que debe abordarse hay una comisión
nacional que debe encargarse de abordar
estos problemas de seguridad lo apoyamos
y francamente nos gustaría ver
que se haga más para asegurar que haya
más seguridad a las personas a nivel
local y también que quienes son
responsables de esos asesinatos
incluyendo a quienes no realizaron
propiamente los asesinatos pero que son
los autores intelectuales de estos
asesinatos también sean llevados ante la
justicia
world of warcraft y que links por guarde
y es el autor y soft y collins daughter
old broads josh muy brevemente también
hemos notado entre los manifestantes una
sensación de decepción respecto al
proceso de paz
qué mensaje les enviaría para que tengan
esperanza o para que crean que todavía
se puede ir por el buen camino
y bueno creo que el primer mensaje sería
que el acuerdo de paz ha mejorado la
situación todavía hay mucho por
implementar del acuerdo de paz
por ningún acuerdo de fase en ninguna
parte del mundo se implementa de la
noche a la mañana
toma tiempo algunos de los elementos de
este acuerdo de paz se pensaron para ser
implementados en un periodo de 15 años y
todavía estamos en el quinto año hay
partes de la implementación que deben
acelerarse
incentivaremos esa aceleración y
seguiremos apoyando y reconociendo lo
que ya se ha logrado y en su actual ex
guardia solo el ipe de swift es en una
última pregunta usted también es
representante especial de derechos
humanos
human rights watch ha reportado más de
20 muertes por violencia policial como
se han visto estas protestas en la unión
europea como las ha visto usted
pistol prosas hemos expresado una gran
preocupación por el asesinato de
manifestantes desarmados y pacíficos
durante el último par de meses y me ha
sorprendido mucho que las personas que
han salido a protestar de manera
pacífica han recibido disparos y en
muchos casos han muerto queremos que
haya una rendición de cuentas hemos
hablado con el presidente hemos hablado
con las autoridades policiales sobre la
necesidad de investigar plenamente estos
sucesos y para que los responsables sean
llevados ante la justicia que vemos
fluyendo hasta que ellos han sido
autores pons provechosos muchas gracias
señor kilmore por haber estado con
nosotros con france24 y muchas gracias a
nuestra audiencia pueden seguir más
contenidos como este en frank 24 y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]